[Music]
everybody welcome to koala zoo episode
18 I believe this is and today I'm
joined by just Mike and Rudy because
unfortunately lady isn't feeling very
well today but I hope you guys are
feeling well how are you doing pretty
good
yeah same I will accept a pollen allergy
but the rest is fine oh yeah I mean I
can imagine speaking about that I I
didn't get that much done in this
episode for a number of reasons first of
all that was of course episode seventeen
and a half earlier this week so I only
have to file for a few days and today
was Good Friday so technically I have
had all day to work on it but I decided
to go out hiking instead there's like
this beautiful forest just outside
Brussels and I live kind of close by and
there's like some some nice hills and
stuff so I ended up going hiking there
instead of working on quality so yeah
that's that's that's my terrible excuse
for this episode not being as horribly
long as some of the other episodes
truthfully I was gonna say truthfully
the bonus episode was about the length
of a collie Zoo episode so consider this
a bonus reel episode yeah and there was
all the 15.5 let's not forget about that
I'm still believing Lady is just not
here because she's getting for the
perfect a piece now again I'm just gonna
stress as a as long as it's possible so
then we're just joking aside joking
aside I'm very happy you went out self
because I am the chili I'm super jealous
of all the people that can do it but I'm
at the same time feeling super happy for
you because honestly if I go out for
half an hour you can forget the rest of
the day for me at the moment
it's insane with the poem it's insane
it's really and honestly speaking I have
also to watch out a little bit because
two times in my life already had a
Chronicle asthma from pollen allergy and
I think that might not be the best idea
to have right now
so yeah I got to stay inside a bit more
because of the pollen you should be good
in in like a week's time but this year
is heavy because basically we had no
winter and yeah but so I'm very happy
you went out because there's a lot more
important stuff yeah to do then just
record I mean not only did we not have
much of a winter it's also like the
corona virus so people aren't traveling
anymore the airs look cleaner nature is
repairing we are the virus all that
stuff so it's like nature is being extra
natural I don't know yeah it's cool
though Thanks what are we going to do
today before we spend yesterday's
terrible Poland yeah it's it's it's it's
time for the the macaque habitat which I
always kind of planned alongside this
chimpanzee habitat I had this idea to
have a big building at the end of the
chimpanzee habitat with an indoor
section for the macaques and the
chimpanzees because we are up in the the
like upper corner of the park next to
the chocolate mountain where all of the
monkeys and apes are located now the
only thing is you might notice that I'm
not actually in the qawalli file because
well my computer can just barely I was I
was pretty fed up with the lag at this
point so I went to a separate file and I
sort of created this mass study to
experiment with and check what kind of
composition would fit into the section
of the park and based on that I just
created a white box and now I'm dressing
up this white box that's kind of clever
yeah that's good yeah it's a simple
system I guess of still trying to work
around my computer's limitations I'm
still not sure to what extent it's just
my computer being terrible or to what
extent it's just the fact that you guys
have NASA supercomputers
but I did notice that my ram is
struggling a lot because I am hitting
the the camp of my RAM which is 16 gigs
and it's only DDR throw so I this is
probably where the bottleneck is largely
located so I'm gonna have to order some
RAM soon and see how that fixes up there
ya go ddr4 I've got 16 ddr4 but yeah
that also runs fine so I guess it did
yeah yeah even the difference there
between ddr3 and it's a difference here
yeah it's huge I remember when I got my
new ones with the new mainboard first I
got the RAM before I got anything else
and it was already a huge improvement
and I remember that we we had basically
kind of the same computer beforehand so
I can tell you that this was significant
this is giving me paradise pure vibes
like theme park rides yeah it is kind of
theme park I'm not gonna lie my actual
inspiration for this were very similar
buildings to the buildings that the
entrance is based on just Dutch colonial
buildings it's very specifically
inspired by a post office in Jakarta
which uses a similar kind of arch at the
entrance which I thought was really cool
and then next to that I found a bunch of
Dutch colonial buildings which have
these towers with small very modest kind
of round spires on top of them and I
figured they would work really well next
to this court as some kind of old
colonial office or post office building
something like this which could be
repurposed into becoming this this
habitat building so it's also kind of
the shell of this building which stands
here at the front but then the building
is a bit larger than that and especially
the whole the the the holding areas for
the animals at the back of it extend
further than the actual traditional
building in the front wall it's given me
the architectural like language of a
train station - yeah that's yeah yeah
totally I love it yeah I think it's it's
that arch with the two towers on this
it's witches yeah definitely very
train-station ii-if not very much a
public building kind of style which I
also think is kind of inherent to Dutch
colonial architecture in Indonesia in
general because it really tends to be
public buildings which get neo-colonial
styles as the train stations and
government buildings and things like
this so you do very often tend to end up
with compositions like this with
colonial architecture I like it I really
do like it especially with the
headlights also I think it's benefiting
a lot from this kind of open feel then
because the whole building seems to be
higher than it actually is because of
having this open middle sector really
really in love with that because it
gives you this feeling of open space
when you get in and you still have the
natural lighting and stuff I'm a big big
big fan of that as well I think it's
also like a bit of museum wipe the old
kind of museums have that so yeah I
really like that it's making me really
think we need to have like a train in
the highlands no but I see this like ooh
this could be really cool how is that
going to fit into the into the final I'm
not sure there's any space left Oh buddy
come on is something in mountain still
has something to offer I believe yeah
there's actually plenty of space up in
chocolate mountain and at the end of the
day also chocolate mountain is not safe
to be removed by Mike so it took a long
time to have what is there I gotta say
terraforming will be if you've Mahara
you know every time you get the file
Mike it will be maybe a bit more leggy
now so terrifying it's good I'm quite
good that you did this early on but for
those people out there I don't know who
of your fear that already but I'm like a
big fan that I discovered this if you
turn vsync off in your file terraforming
magically is a lot more smooth like
exactly a new tool honestly believe me
it's insane I just turned that off
because I thought okay maybe it's giving
me a few more frames and you don't
notice the frames but you do notice that
the terraforming tool I don't know if
you also notice up and when you use it
it's kind of a little bit delayed like
that you push this is gone like the
delay is gone and it's very it's like an
instant there and that's so cool if you
turn it off it works like really mean
well and it's so much easier to do the
little details and stuff so I can only I
can only recommend turn off vsync for a
moment and it's gonna work wonders cool
it was all thanks totally unintended
that I found this was just a coincidence
but yeah it works
mm-hmm yeah I'm definitely gonna try
that especially here I had to do a
little bit of terraforming eventually
but with my already Park laggy Park
final thing like lag just stacked on top
of each other at terraforming became
nearly impossible that's definitely one
of the worst parts for me yeah I can
believe and it felt so good to work in
this empty pool and just be completely
like for you like yeah I know when I go
back to an old project like my Botanical
Gardens I'm like oh this is how the
keister it's also like you don't notice
it anymore like if you work in a file
for a while and it just starts getting
laggy and thank you but you don't go to
a different empty file you just get used
to them and only when you start
something new you're just like oh yeah
this was always the same with that
parent coaster I remember going back to
Eastern apollyon that like I build in
that like I seriously did build here
[Laughter]
it's saying yeah the things we do for
love it's a piece that's really simple
so in terms of polygons not a whole lot
here that's true yeah it's not so bad
this is actually the the show
what happened partly in plane coaster I
remember that we took very complicated
pieces these brackets were sometimes
very decorated and very crazy in terms
of polygons and and we basically only
used the only flat side of that [ __ ]
yeah absolutely yeah I think actually I
love the South American pack for all of
the small pieces that it has these these
stone pieces are so versatile and you
can do so much with them whether it be
custom wall textures or roof tiles or
anything like that it's really cool to
have these small bits that you can put
here and there to make your own
detailing we're in the park now or are
you doing though no we were in the for
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we're in the park
now because it's time to get into
terraforming and rook work and foliage
and all that so I had to start putting
up with the lag to be honest it isn't
that bad right now like I think I'm
still on a solid 15 frames per second so
it's not like worse than the last
episode it's just when it comes to all
that detailing on the building and
putting a bunch of pieces down like that
I really wanted to work you know with a
decent frame and plop it in already and
good to go you might have noticed I did
a little bit of interior work this
building was actually partly inspired by
some of the lady's work especially the
the reptile house mmm which has it sort
of takes some cues of the layouts and
overall roof structure from it and then
also on the inside it has some concrete
walls but with the same fading green
color on the walls as the the Panda
that's that that's cool that's really
cool I love how the building has a
different elevation step to the left
hand side you can really see that this
this initially normal building that
potentially was on a very solid ground
got opened up to the left-hand side
where the habitat goes in and it has
been repurposed I love that feel of it
yeah yeah it's definitely I definitely
quite chipped away at it with the
terrain it also feels kind of like I
think the the indoor sections are shoe
into this building structure because it
clearly looks like a building that
wasn't you know men's houses super
realistic recreated natural habitat or
anything like this but it sort of
reclaimed and brought into this context
nonetheless although I have to say I
didn't do that much interior work so
don't pay too much attention to it I'm
not banking on a mic revamped of course
though if you would like to do it it's
totally fine but it's just quite a
simple placeholder version for the time
being if I don't fix that reptile house
the lady is going to murder me
I remember the spec set is still open oh
yeah yep so that is a that is where I
wanted to somehow actually down here fix
the macaques sorry speaking of backsides
oh that's that's a horrible
that's a horrible transition I'm never
going to say speaking of back sides but
yeah speaking of this one's also open
yeah but I somehow had to had to
shoehorn a macaque habitat in there so
like all of this is kind of preparing
for the eventual struggle that is going
to be that oh I forgot but first I'm
actually building this bridge I totally
forgot about that what a bridge but it's
more just like a support structure I
guess I noticed that there haven't been
any supports for the single track of the
monorail like any point where the to
monorails
mm-hmm aligned there are these double
support structures but I noticed that
wasn't the case anywhere where it was
just a single track so I was trying to
figure out how to support this place
because it's going over the habitat here
but I ended up having to build some sort
of bridge to keep this thing supported
because yeah I just can't have supports
going into the habitat I think that's
true actually you kind of break the mood
a little bit and yeah oh yeah I totally
get that you did a wonderful job
unfortunately this track is moving Oh No
oh by the way that you did this though
I'm gonna take that into consideration
this is an interesting technique yeah
yeah so that's alike I had to get a
perfect circular arch shape so the
easiest way to do that in the quickest
way was to just make a flat circle with
the dome technique and then just take
that thing
delete most of the circle and put this
thing underneath it because it's kind of
a very annoying bridge because it's also
curved and then I need an arch
underneath that which is like vertically
arching but also follows the curve of
the track for a video well it's it's
never lost at least we have this time
lapse okay we can look at it appreciate
but will forever be lost in the archive
and who knows maybe because the the
monorail is very limiting in terms of
how much it can bend this monorail track
anyways so in terms of how the angle or
the radius of the corners on turns will
be it's not gonna change too
dramatically no matter where it is so
maybe we can use it again mm perhaps
although I also have to say it's not the
end of the world that it's gonna get
deleted because you will see at the end
when it comes to the sight lines
especially from the area where the
chimpanzees are the bridge is kind of in
the way like it kind of looks the view
of the building a little bit and it's
not horrible I mean I think it adds some
interesting layered Ness to the view but
without the bridge I think you would
work really fine yeah I kind of realized
that as we were building up this area
this monorail is just in the way and it
needs to go around the like the path of
least resistance so so what is going to
be the path of least resistance for it
because I have no idea where that thing
it's probably go geez you built here -
okay yeah so actually cool now it's
gonna start being very funny because now
the space skin there
and everyone is trying to fit stuff in
and my Casas plan for the whole pot
maybe main like you need to draw out
your plan what I what I realize is that
having it curve up over area next to the
orangutangs
it just didn't though the way that I was
trying to protect the the monorail
didn't make sense I wanted to use
something straight so that I could have
glass tunnels and so it's just gonna go
straight through and kind of grace the
the temple area a little bit but I was
going to do that in a way where you
don't really see the track or anything
interesting challenge yeah so now that
this is in place here and that limit
coxa can be located here what is there
what is the next plan of attack then no
look at the file again but I don't think
I don't think it's my turn next it's a
Rudy's next yeah to be honest I really
am also struggling a little bit I had
the idea to potentially bring some
llamas in but I am a little bit
struggling with with how and where they
could fit because you know they there
are quite a bit more mountainous you
know they need a little bit more stuff
to climb on and to go up and down so it
might not make sense to bring them
closer to the entrance so we might need
to look into how this fits into the
mountain area maybe but also I I did
also I'm actually favoring this at the
moment so I'm not sure what I'm going to
do out of those two but I'm also looking
into some kind of reintroduction program
because people were commenting a lot
lately that we have a little bit of a
lack of education and at the moment I'm
like we have this one Education Center
which is quite from the very beginning
which was my first episode you did an
overhaul but I think that was the the
only education center we have so far so
I had the idea of building like kind of
an reintroduction center where we could
have yeah some example habitats that are
not filled like potentially just a few
habitat ideas and then just have some
info science about this where people can
get educated about how different things
work in habitats and why they have been
done the way and yeah maybe have also
and edits backstitch every other we can
have like a veterinarian habitat because
I figured we also do not have that good
also I have a tab for veterinarians you
can look at them that's ruining
veterinarians this is very interesting
to look at as well and if we don't treat
them well enough some protesters to the
protester corner I was about to say we
still have some in here so that
shouldn't be too beautiful to issue but
no but actually a house is actually
called English it's a medical is a
medical habitat where you would bring
them because the zoo's most likely have
this by habit ok all you know where yeah
yeah it's like animal is there and
quarantine not something then no it's
like I am in like an incubation habitat
or something where they can keep an eye
on the animals like they're trying to
get them back out into the display these
are the two things I have on my list but
yeah who knows and I'm definitely not
gonna do both I guess because so that's
not that much time I have next week so
maybe focusing on but you never know
with me you never know then you're
really getting into the education theme
especially also after some of your
earlier stuff with the Education Center
as well
yeah I you know the thing is I I tried
to do this quite a bit more often
because like the thing is I'm super
interested about the research doing the
research and getting myself informed
about this because I find this really
interested interesting because like
habitat things are quite you know after
a time you do know about some things how
habits not work and this I won't say
it's gonna get boring but there are some
standards you're always using it's
getting a bit more repetitive but but
with these some education things I feel
like there's so much to explore and and
how different things work with animals
why different things are made I find it
super interesting and that's the the
sole reason and this is also the sole
reason why I lightly tackle the Arctic
pack in a way that and then I think no
one else did I built this Arctic
research station and instead of a zoo
because I figured that and
most likely or not in a zoo so that
won't make sense and yeah I think it's
just very interesting because the game
offers you just kind of yeah creativity
to try and build that and you know there
are some ways to get people get there
and be interested you can still fool
them guests so what is this gonna work
yeah yeah I think we have to assume that
we're probably gonna have Vista points
at some point yeah I really do hope so
frontier uh-huh listening if they're
watching and be pretty great yeah so
just to get back into the the habitat
for a bit this is where I decided to
have some sort of viewing platform and
for the longest time I couldn't figure
out how to make this thing work because
I wanted some kind of platform where I
get a good in-depth look at the
mechanics but I didn't want to destroy
the view of well basically any place
that you're looking at the orangutangs
from and I also wanted to allow people
to look at the orangutan habitat from
this perspective as well because I don't
know it's such a big such a huge habitat
with so many different areas and so many
different viewing platforms as well that
I figured might as well at this at the
back of the temple the temple actually
looks pretty cool from up here you kind
of see the temple in the foreground but
then you you look down almost down into
the valley if the rest of the the rest
of the zoo
that's kind of cool but I of course
wanted to focus mostly on the macaques
so I ended up just settling for a very
simple bamboo shade based platform we're
kind of going up into the trees and
looking at least two habitats yeah it's
really really simple so that your your
eye isn't caught by it and like you
showed in the pictures that you can't
see this structure at all when you're
looking up at the temple which is
amazing yeah that's really cool yeah
everything is everything is kind of
about sight lines in this episode which
you don't get to see in the time that's
because I just took some time every time
before building something to see okay
how is this gonna be located what's it
gonna look like because there's so much
to be careful about right now at this
point because all of the parts in the
zoo have very carefully constructed
sight lines will you see some things and
some
things are carefully obstructed from the
view and for the temple this goes
especially because you see it from a
bunch of places and I really had to make
sure that from these places that you
could see the temple from you aren't
able to see this new building and vice
versa so that was kind of a big struggle
here so a lot of it comes into the
interplay with the foliage that's just
putting trees everywhere to obscure the
view mostly very cool
by the way I just want to mention self
do not complain again about the foliage
introductions of everyone else because I
just saw you popping down trees into the
ground for bushes like like a madman I
just want to add though I don't know I
think you guys had trouble with that as
well this is the only way to really do
not destroy the traversable area right
so it's got to be done because you get
some cool bushes and some cool ground
effects without actually destroying the
traversable area it's kind of a thing I
really hope that maybe front you can
look into because some of the bushes are
like elephant grass for example it looks
super good but it kind of destroys your
whole habitat because the Bronx is yeah
I don't know so yeah I also find it
strange because animals always start
floating on top of it because it just
looks so good but every now and then you
just see yeah I I got to say I basically
removed this from every project I made
so far like I put it in and it's like
looking super good but it's just not
practical that's a bit of it's a bit of
a downer because it really looks cool
and you can use it for Gardens it's
awesome amazing but as soon as someone
has to interact with it I love by the
way a little planter you did over here
what's now that little doe but I love
this planter I love the slopes just
looking at the slow inclines off it's
just it makes me slow very very gradual
inclines all over this thing although
I'm also glad that the natural
environment just kind of forced me to do
this because otherwise maybe it's just
my my Dutch background but otherwise I
just like to lie
oh damn it yeah now you are the one you
can make some jokes about that let's
keep on going with the with the Dutch
jokes I felt it was a bit too German
heavy lately so I mean I just feel like
there are more good jokes about German
people it's just maybe this is more
stereotypes piers well that was it for
this episode I'm just gonna leave y'all
with some a cinematic photos because I I
tried cheese engineering the the heck
out of my game and even that didn't say
so I'd like to thank y'all in the
audience for watching this video I want
to thank you Rudy and Mike for coming to
record this with me you're very welcome
yep same alright and we'll see each
other next week oh really
alright bye guys bye bye absolutely stay
safe have a good weekend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you